- You also have two sons.
So that's, I have a
boy and boys are crazy.
They like to just, it's like
little Tasmanian devils.
So, I mean, have they, have
they picked up on anything,
any of your habits I hear they maybe have,
and is it a healthy habit?
- I think it's a fun habit.
You know, I've got two boys.
I am 42 years old and I, to this day,
believe that the funniest thing
in the world is our farts.
And so I almost the first
opportunity that I had, basically,
as soon as they could
like move their hands,
I had them pulling my finger and you know,
they're six and three years old now.
And even the six year old, I still, he,
they still believe I
don't want them to walk in
and hear this,
but they still believe that
they are actually pulling the
gas out of me by pulling my finger.
And we just laugh and laugh.
It is just fantastic.
- I love it.
It's like such a.
- They have it.
- Such 14 year old humor.
- They're like my finger.
Oh, it's just so much fun.
- Oh God I love you, but we'll
do you, people has asked me,
you know, oh, if your kids are singers,
do people ask you about your kids?
Like if they were actors,
would you be into that or not?
- Not right now.
You know, I was, I was a kid actor.
I started when I was five years old.
So it is pretty surreal.
You know, my son is,
my oldest is six now.
So it's crazy to look at him
and know that at his age I was
working professionally and
had an agent and everything.
- Wow.
And so I have no regrets.
I'm incredibly grateful for my experience.
And it, it has everything
to do with where I'm at now
in my career
having that experience.
But I would not put them
in it now that's for sure.
But if they want to, when
they get older, you know,
they're both little hams, you know,
they certainly seem to have
inherited some performance,
you know, inclinations.
So we'll see.
- Well, just from this
interview, I can tell you,
they get the humor from you.
I haven't met her,
but so they're going to be funny.
- She's way funnier than I am.
She's way funnier than I am.
- Oh my God, I love her already.
All right, well wait.
You are, you were speaking about
how you were a child actor.
So you were in some fast food commercials
when you were a kid?
- Yeah, yeah.
- How was that?
- I've been in all kinds of commercials.
- How was that though It's awkward, right?
- Yeah, it's, it's kind of awkward.
I actually did do,
I did one fast food commercial
where a major lesson was
imparted on me.
I had to eat a burger
in every take, you know,
this beautiful looking beautifully
prepared burger for this
fast food chain.
And I ate and they kept
coming in after we cut.
And they were like, do
you want to spit it out?
Do you want to throw it away?
And I would just be like, no,
this is awesome.
I could eat burgers all day.
And I just would stuff my face.
And of course,
by the end of the day I was sick.
I didn't eat.
it was like on December 23rd
and we filmed it right around
the holidays.
And I remember I didn't
eat another full meal until
Christmas dinner.
And so I, now anytime
I have to eat something
in any scene whatsoever,
I immediately dispose of
it after camera stops.
So, you know, listen, that's a,
it's a big lesson and I hope
that I've just imparted it on,
you know, other upcoming
actors out there watching.
- You're welcome.